these aren't grave robbers but a family
the who's the who's mean to unburied
their grandmother clean her bones then
bury her again in the family pagoda
where her spirit will be reunited with
her loved ones
it's an ancient sacred ritual called
second burial in Taiwan
many families dig up their dead and bury
them a second time
often to consolidate ancestral remains
at one sacred site wishing to honor
their grandmother with a second burial
the Hoos call in professionals the Wong
family
the Wong's meet the Hoos at the
graveyard on a dating best by a
geomancer and expert in shoes law
resting places for the dead at
grandmother's grave father and sons
start the heavy work in the United
States when the person dies is a time
for grief when we pick the bones of the
deceased people are in the happy because
picking the bones means to refurbish the
body of the deceased and to move him to
a new residence the grave is opened and
swept until every piece of bone is found
and tagged at the Wang family
headquarters the Hoos select an urn for
grandmother's bones for now her remains
will take a place in the line of bones
waiting to be cleaned the Wang brothers
get to work on the backlog of other
clients bones first they clean the bones
of dirt and flesh and reassemble the
skeleton every phase of bone cleaning
has a reason and meaning rooted in
tradition
if the rituals aren't followed precisely
the ancestors could become angry and
take it out on the living paint is mixed
with wine to symbolically reflect at
last the Wong's pack the bones in an urn
after her bones are cleaned grandmother
who won't leave the Wang storehouse
right away it may be months before
geomancer chooses an auspicious day for
her second burial when her urn would be
placed in the pagoda mr. foo built
exclusively for his family we believe we
have the luxury of living in a nice
then we should provide our ancestors a
better place to live -
with a full heart mr. who will soon lay
his grandmother to rest again and
fulfill his sacred duty to the dead